what in the world is going on what is
going on I mean what does it mean to be
incarnate in a human body in a squirrely
culture like this trying to make sense
of your your heritage your opportunities
the contents of the culture the contents
of your own line is it possible to have
an overarching viewpoint that is not
somehow canned or cultish or self
limited in its approach in other words
is it possible to cultivate an open mind
and sanity in the kind of society and
psychological environment that we all
share and it grows daily and weekly as
you know harder to do this weirder to
integrate more on your plate to
assimilate and I certainly don't have
final or even merely final answers I
think at all lies in posing the
questions in a certain way in feeling
the data in a certain way and one of the
things I try to convince people is it's
not necessary to achieve closure with
this stuff and in fact any ideological
or belief system that offers closure
meaning final answers is sure to be
wrong sure to be self-limiting sure to
be inadequate to the facts so one of the
ideas I'd like to put out is
that an amazing strange in this man but
perhaps not the idea that ideology is
not our friend it is not a matter of
choosing from a smartest board of
ideologies and rejecting the flawed the
self contradictory and this over simple
in favor of the un-- flawed the complex
enough where is it written in adamantine
that semi carnivorous monkeys can or
should be capable of understanding
reality that seems to me one of the
first delusions of and one of the more
prideful illusions of human culture that
a final understanding is possible in the
first place better I think to try and
frame questions which can do questions
which cannot doer and leave off
searching for answers because answers
are like operating systems they're being
upgraded faster than you can keep up
with it thank you for watching if you
found enjoyment and value in this video
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our channel we are constantly coming
out with new videos to help you
experience life with clarity and wonder